انتقد رئيس اكبر هيئه تجاريه للشركات
الطيران في العالم القيود المفروضه على
السفر ضد المسافرين من الصين بحجه ان مثل
هذه التدابير قد ثبت انها غير فعاله في
منع انتشار كورونا المدير العام الاتحاد
الدولي للنقل الجوي ايايتا عبر عن اسافه
جراء عوده قيود كورونا في بعض المطارات
مجددا ااه رغم ثبوت فشل تلك القيود طيله
ثلاث سنوات ماضيه على حددي تعبيره
في هذه الاثناء تواصل الصين مكافحه
تتفشيرون بعد تخليها عن سياسه صفر» التي
لطال ما تبعتها حيث اعلنت سلطاته الاربعاء
عن خمسه وفيات بسبب الفايروس مقارنه لثلاث
وفايات سجلتها الثلاثاء الماضي
مما رفع العدد الرسمي للوفيات الى نحو
خمسه الاف وفاه البيانات الصينيه
على حد معرفتي فان اربعه من اقارب اي من
عائله واحده ماتوا بالفعل لذلك املوا ان
تخبر الحكومه بامانه ومصداقيه شعبها وشعوب
العالم بما حدث بالفعل هنا
2020 و 2021 وعندما تفشل الفيروس في
الخارج اتخذت الصين ايضا اجراءات مماثله
بما في ذلك تعليق بعض الرحلات الجويه ربما
دفعت كثافه الاجراءات التي اتخذتها الصين
في السابق دولا اخرى لاتخاذ اجراءات اكثر
جديه ضد المسافرين القادمين من الصين لذلك
يمكنني ان افهم هذا النوع من الاشياء
في غضون ذلك قال رئيس الوزراء اليمني
فوميو تشيجا ان بلاده ستلزم القادمين من
الصين باجراء اختبار سلبيه مؤكدا ان
اليابان ستتخذ جميع التدابير ممكنه
لمراقبه حدودها منع لتفشل الفايروس
اختبار بي سي ار على القادمين من الصين
الى اليابان سنلزمهم بتقديم نتائج اختبار
سلبيه القادمين عبر رحلات مباشره من الصين
اضافه الى ذلك سنتخذوا جميع التدابير
الممكنه لمراقبه الحدود وسنستمر ايضا في
وضع قيود اللازمتي على الرحلات الجويه
الاضافيه من الصين
زومبي
يعقد مسؤوله الصحفي دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
ليوم اجتماعا بشان تنسيق الاستجابه لزياده
حالات الاصابه بفيروس كورونا في الصين قبل
ذلك ايدت الغالبيه العظمى من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي اجراء اختبارات كوبيد بشكل منهج
المسافرين القادمين من الصين وفق ما اعلن
ناطق باسم المفوضيه الاوروبيه وهذا
الاجراء هو جزء من توصياتنا اعتمدت خلال
اجتماع لمسؤوليه الصحه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي عقد في بروكسيل امس وبحث الخبراء
ايضا في تدابير اخرى اقتراحتها المفوضيه
الاوروبيه بما في ذلك مطالبه المسافرين
الصينيين بوضع الكمامات وزياده الاختبارات
من اجل تحديد متحولات جديده محتمله
وفرضت العديد من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي بما
فيها فرنسا واسبانيا وايطاليا اجراء
اختبار على الوافدين من الصين في انتظار
ان تتواصل الكتله او تتوصل الكتله الى نهج
موحد
من جهتي استنكرت بكين القيود المتزايده
التي تطبقها ايضا الولايات المتحده
واليابان واستراليا
وهددت باتخاذ التدابير مضاده مبنيه على
مبدا المعامله بالمثل
واعتبرت الصين ان قرار دول بفرد قيود على
مواطنها يفتقر الى اساس علمي بحسب ما صرحت
الخارجيه الصينيه
صحيفه الشعب اليوميه الصينيه الرسميه قالت
ان السلطات ستحقق النصر في نهايه المطاف
رغم مخاوف وقلق عالمي من تفشي الفايروس
معي نور الدين فريدي من بريكسال مراسل
العربيه نور الدين اهلا بك هل من سياسه
موحده للاتحاد الاوروبي تجاه المسافرين
القادمين من الصين هل ممكن ان يكون هناك
قرار واحد
الدبلوماسيون وخبراء الصحه في الدول
الاعضاء ال 27 امكانيات التوصل الى
اجراءات احترازيه المشتركه
من صعود المسافر الى الطائره في الصين حتى
الاجراءات الاخرى التي ستليه وصوله او ما
يتعلق بالمطاراتي بمعنى ان هناك همم قبل
الاجتماع الشعور بوجود اغلبيه تساند
مراجعه الفحوصات السلبيات لدى المسافرين
قبل سعودي من الطائره اذا ساعدوا الى
الطائره ومعهم هذه الفحوصات السلبيه فانهم
يطالبون بلبس الكماماتيه وعندما تصل
الطائره تحط الطائره في المطارات
الاوروبيه هناك اقتراح يبحث في نزول
الساعتين المقبلتين بان يتم جمع مياه
الصرف الصحي او مياه المياه المستخدمه في
الطائرات الوافده من لماذا لتحليلي سواء
كان ما يتعلق تحليل العينات للبحث عن همم
سلاسل الجينيه
للمتحور او ربما متحورات فيروسيه جديده
هذا اضافه الى همم هناك نوع من الاجراءات
المتنوعه المتعدده بعض الدول مثل فرنسا لا
تقوموا بالاجراء بالفحوصات مثلا في المطار
وانما تترك السائح باعتبار انه وصل همم
بفحص السلبيه ثم تقوم باجراءات او فحوصات
عشوائيه بعد وصول الوفد السياحي هذا الامر
يختلف ربما يتم توحيد ذلك في قبول
والايام المقبله
صحيه ام سياسيه بعض الشيء ضد الصين او
تجاه الصين يعني هل سيس الموضوع الصحي
لا هو فعلا موضوع صحي في الايام الماضيه
هدات او هدا المسؤولون الوضع لاننا لان
اوروبا او المدن الاوروبيه كانت تجتاز
اعياد الميلاد واعياد راس السنه الان
الموضوع صحي ولكن مطمئن اذا اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار في جمله ما قاله المركز الاوروبي
للوقايه
ومراقبه الامراض من ان الفيروسات او
المتحولات الموجوده في الصين هي منتشره
ايضا في اوروبا التطعيم المرتفع نسبيا في
في اوروبا مقارنه الوضع مطمئن في نظري
المركز الاوروبي للوقايه من الامراض
الاوروبي ايضا غير اللقاح الصيني
والامريكاني ايضا شكرا لك من بروكسيل
مراسل العربيه نور الدين شكرا
[موسيقى]